would you ever use
uh
alexa or siri or you know like for
fearless lectures built into our new
lucid
and we can use our it has carplay apple
carplay and android auto so you can use
your phone as your navigation and other
things so so you're not concerned about
them listening in and
you know all of this uh well actually
yeah sort of concerned but i also
like alexa in my home
and we have for example i'll plot my
phone sometimes when we're driving home
and i'll i'll call alex and i'll tap in
and i'll drop into the the alexa in our
kitchen i'll start talking to the dogs
and they you hear me
yelp and mommy and daddy are coming
i just remember there was
at some point i think i might have
bought bought some product and and then
i was setting it up and and it asked me
i was prompted we do want to use alexa
and it said like
it it's going to record
yeah i was like
when i see those kind of warnings you
know yeah and the iphone is really good
about telling you nowadays if something
you're doing might get you into being
observed watch shared
and get known i go know as much as i can
on that and i use
oh i forget what they call it that hides
your ip address
oh yeah yeah vpn no
vpn's one thing i even built my own on a
raspberry pi i built my own um open vpn
the best vpn there is in my home on a
real ip address that i have real ipv4 so
when i'm overseas i can even use my own
vpn instead of others that are known
their their server dresses are known and
you know the countries you're in that
don't like you doing everything can spot
those addresses and block them yeah vpn
but vpn's one way but no apple i forget
what they call it oh my gosh it's it's a
little catchy two-word phrase kind of
but it means you're going you're going
with your ip address hidden from
everything oh okay yeah apple's gotten a
lot better with privacy
and that's they stand for it yeah they
stand for it maybe it's just by accident
that wound up where they were worth what
they had but i'm so glad for that i want
to be uh
you know what we share photos in our
families on on on icloud costs two
dollars a month right you share photos
with albums and other friends of the
family and can be in on it
and and
it's protected it's private nobody can
take the data you know and find out
everything you're doing so it's
but but uh facebook says oh apple is so
expensive they can do that two dollars a
month why don't you do it no just let us
pay for privacy on on facebook that's my
biggest problem of all big tech
facebook's number one
that i don't like i mean you gotta be in
the social web but i don't
so i i pretty much avoid all the social
web
i mean i had facebook i had facebook for
a lot of years never used it and i wound
up saying yes to everybody want to be a
friend so i had 5 000 facebook friends
all people i don't know
and then then for three months i
actually went and started looking at
facebook because i kind of like little
videos of dogs being dogs and big dogs
being saved by people no this is true i
spent an hour every night on tick tock
just waiting for that nice little to see
that and um and and then i found that
whenever i was at an airport i was
flying a lot back then like 200 flights
a year i'd just be find myself scrolling
through and i said if i have solitaire i
don't need this
because it became so habit for me and
after three months yeah and i don't like
habits because that's
addiction yeah that's addiction and i
want to be i think for myself and choose
what i'm going to do so i i totally we
dropped facebook janet and i just
dropped our accounts
deactivated them didn't quite drop them
so i'm still scared a bit i took had to
take facebook off my devices because i
read how it can still grab data and
facebook even when you're not using it
right i i don't believe this is right
because you should have it honest that
every person who uses it knows what
they're doing like steve would post
something and i would click like
you know i'm laughing i'd click like
it's from me to steve
wait a minute
no it's not to steve he doesn't ever see
it it's from me to 100 advertisers
yeah learning things about me learning
things about me and
that is just shocking because that's not
how we think of it we think like is a
way that i can actually
indicate what i like and not that it's
being used to advertise to me and if
you're a creative person as some of us
are you don't want people to know what
you're going to say next what you're
going to do next where you're going to
shop what you're going to buy when we
should when we should give you this
alert and all the time i notice that
sometimes devices that sort of guess on
me guess you know you'll want to do this
now
no today i've got something else going
on you know or traffic is not this way
today because it's it's a midweek
holiday
and and this algorithm just don't know
what a dumbest human knows and they used
to make it sound like oh artificial
intelligence will be like a human we
have eyes the tesla has has cameras and
it'll be able to do what a human does
and trouble is we don't know how the
brain's wired we do not know how the
brain does that stuff
i know because i was a psychology major
and we don't even know that our memories
are in the brain
memory of this medium here don't know
that's in the brain i took all the
strongest subjects in memory and
psychology
and read every book i could and went
walking on the streets of berkeley and
buying more books from the older days
and where's memory the best they had
will must be everywhere because you take
any part of the brain out and no memory
gets lost from the rat so it must be
everywhere wow
but now i came up with something 40
years ago
i have to go back well 1981 whatever
that was 40 years ago
i i came up with a statement to to make
fun of the fact that the books don't
know anything i said the strongest
correlation you can come up with is that
between the ages of 6 and 10 as we had
learned you lose two things
your childhood autobiographic memories
things that you've done as a child and
you lose your teeth
right and that's the strongest best
correlation now it's 20 22 or something
one of these years 20 21 i don't know
what it is i don't do years but you can
look up you you can search for teeth
memory you're going to shock what you
find today so not to mention alzheimer's
tests in the saliva and the gums you're
saying maybe your childhood memories are
in your
teeth i was saying there's no way
memories are stored in teeth okay
that's what i'm saying but if i say but
i have a stronger
more
logical mathematical explanation of
where memories could be than you'll find
in any book
i would just point out how weak the
books were nobody listened to me of
course i wrote it up for the professor
but
do you oh sorry stephen i was just like
it reminds me of uh the the thing that i
came up with
which is that uh my theory
that
the brain does not
generate consciousness the brain is not
a transmitter of consciousness but
rather it's a receiver and and so i have
this uh this metaphor
and this analogy to to describe what i'm
saying is that um
we're we're like a radio kind of yeah a
lot of people want to hear that and you
know all the knowledge of the world is
in waves but you know what i just i just
disown anything that says we can have
between people you know some psychic
connection through the air i always
disown it all right telepathy
yeah you don't think telepathy is
possible
correct like the men who stare at goats
is all [ __ ] probably i don't know
that one but i just i just think that uh
you know like like it you could take
your your body like uh kill the body
but but you're not killing the
consciousness you know like i don't buy
that okay but then i accept you you have
good you have a good thinking if you
start with that as your assumption yes
you can come up with yes there's
something out there i can't disprove it
right so you're just as good as you're
thinking just as good as mine mine just
always wanted you know mathematical
scientific proofs you can all go circuit
together and see a like i love that too
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]